Asalamu allayikum Dr. Zakinum.
I am Pritam Das from Kolkata 32 years
old. I am a reverted Muslim. I was
raised in a Hindu family. I accepted
Islam in 2014 on my own. I also need a
certificate. Alhamdulillah. I'm a proud
practicing Muslim for last 10 years. I
have been raised in Kolkata. I've been
propagating Islam for last 10 years on
all my social media platforms. Dr. Sab,
I am 80% physically challenged. Neither
I can walk nor can I stand on my feet. I
have completed the whole Quran Sharif
thrice and the fourth time is going on.
Alhamdulillah. Dr. Sab, they sent police
to my house on 21st December 2022 and
literally stole my phone without my
consent. Alhamdulillah they found
nothing and returned it the next time.
It has strengthened my iman even more.
Alhamdulillah I was to contact you Dr. S
for my certificate. I am from Kolkata.
Can you help me? I can also keep on
saying
I bear witness that there is no god but
Allah and prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him is the last and final messenger of
almighty Allah four billion times
constitutionally they can't stop me
propagating Islam inshallah I will
continue to dawa all my online platforms
till my last breath Dr. Dr. S, I don't
know how to connect with you. Please
help me. I'm not scared of them by any
means. I fear none but Allah alone. Dr.
Sab, please contact on my email. I'll be
waiting for your response. My birth name
was Pritam Das. I want to change it to
Pritam Mustafa or else suggest me a name
according to your choice but please help
me Dr. S. The brother mainly Priam Das
is a revert. accepted Islam 10 years
ago, but he has not been able to get an
official certificate or a document
saying that he has reverted to Islam.
He's asking him help. Inshallah, I have
your email. I have your contact. I'll
ask one of my friends to contact you and
see to that inshallah very soon you get
an official document from a lawyer which
is illegal that you have accepted Islam.
Inshallah it may take a couple of weeks
but somebody will contact you and
inshallah we'll see to it that you get
this certificate and I pray to Allah
subhanaa tala that may you be on the
straight path and the way with
conviction you said that we'll keep on
saying the shada we'll keep on
properating Islam irrespective what
happens I pray to Allah subhanana wa
tala to keep you on the straight path to
keep you steadfast and may through you
get hundreds of non-Muslims to Islam
hope that answers the